bonjour et bienvenue au parlement
européen à strasbourg pour un nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo
au menu cette semaine le pnr passage her
name ricort d'un nouvel outil dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est le sujet d'un conseil européen
cette semaine la commission des libertés
civiles du parlement européen a approuvé
le projet d'un fichier européen des
données des passagers aériens objectifs
premiers repérés à temps les vols des
jihadistes de retour en europe
ensuite on ira en espagne les élections
législatives la base c'est le 20
décembre prochain et on se posera la
question suivante va tourner vers la fin
du bipartisme dans la péninsule ibérique
un de nouveaux partis font surface
un coup de jeune dans la scène politique
espagnole mais d'abord la première
partie de notre émission de nouveaux
outils dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
bruxelles veut créer un corps de gardes
frontières pour sécuriser schengen autre
outil le pnr au fait le pnrc quoi tout
de suite les explications et ont réagi
juste après avec nos invités
pnr passenger name recode un fichier
pour garder les données sur les
passagers de chaque avion objectif
premier à repérer à temps les vols des
djihadistes que l'on n'avait pas vue
revenir vers l'europe
mais pour cela le pnr doit afficher tout
le monde déjà quand vous achetez
aujourd'hui un billet en france pour les
états unis
vous êtes fiché dans le pnr américain
votre billet va comporter coder une
quinzaine d' informations très
personnelles numéros d'identité numéro
de téléphone de carte bancaire votre
itinéraire ou encore votre régime
alimentaire halal ou casher des données
spécial collectées dont ne veulent pas
les européens pour de nombreux
eurodéputés le pnr américain mais pas
transposable tel quel en europe
en gros en français comme en ont le
droit de la plupart des états membres
toute la collection de données reposent
sur un certain nombre de règles
on ne peut pas constituer des fichiers
pourquoi parce qu'on veut pas faire un
fichier des juifs on veut pas faire un
fichier les arabes on veut pas faire un
fichier des gens qui n'aiment pas telle
ou telle chose
donc c'est un risque majeur pour les
libertés
la semaine dernière la commission des
libertés civiles du parlement européen a
approuvé le projet d'un fichier européen
des données des passagers aériens depuis
londres le ministre de l'intérieur salue
les avancées vers l'adoption du pnr même
s'il veut aller plus loin
il ya un sujet qui pour moi est centrale
et sur lequel je vais mener la bataille
dans les mois qui viennent c'est
l'alimentation du système d'information
schengen par l'ensemble des services de
renseignements de l'union parce que si
les services de renseignements de
l'union n'alimente pas le système
d'information schengen l'interrogation
des fichiers au moment du franchissement
des frontières extérieures sera plein de
failles
débattue depuis cette année au total le
projet doit encore être adopté en séance
publique en janvier probablement leur
pas trancher sur plusieurs points le pnr
sera établi pour les vols internationaux
et les vols intérieurs
les données seront conservées pendant
six mois elles seront masqués au bout de
ce délai est effacé après cinq ans le
texte affirme que toute discrimination
basée sur l'origine ethnique ou sociale
la religion la langue ou la nationalité
du passager sera évitée les etats unis
disent avoir tiré les leçons du 11
septembre leur pnr leur aurait permis de
tracer un tiers des terroristes
potentiels qu'ils avaient identifié en
voilà nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
deux eurodéputés français d'abord arnaud
danjean bonjour vous êtes eurodéputé
membre du ppe en france vous êtes membre
des républicains avant de faire de la
politique vous avez travaillé pour la
dgse est mené dans ce cadre des missions
au kosovo pendant la guerre qui frappa
le pays en face de vous il y indique
jadot vous êtes député européen
écologiste et élu sous les couleurs
d'europe écologie les verts vice
président de la commission commerce
international du parlement européen est
particulièrement sensible aux questions
de libertés publiques je me trompe pas
on vient de voir le sujet le pnr est ce
qu il fallait le faire après les
attentats qui ont frappé paris il ya un
mois si je peux me permettre par rapport
aux sujets qu'on vient de voir le pnr ne
va pas créer un fichier dans lequel on
va mettre tout et n'importe quoi sur
tout le monde
le pnrc des données qui existe déjà
c'est les compagnies aériennes qui est
qu'ils ont déjà ces données quand vous
faites vos réservations d'avion
le pnr à l'européenne c'est quoi c'est
permettre aux services de police et de
renseignement des pays membres d'aller
piocher dans ces données qui existent
qui sont déjà collectés mais auquel ils
n'ont pas accès aujourd'hui d'aller
piocher dans ces données au coup par
coup et dans un cadre légal c'est-à-dire
avec un certain nombre de dispositions
qui évite que justement on collectionne
de façon massive on collecte pardon de
façon massive ces données de façon
indiscriminée
donc par rapport à ce qu'on vient
d'entendre une petite nuance quand même
il s'agit d'un dispositif qui n'est pas
moi je les dis nombreuses reprises qui
n'est pas la baguette magique dans
l'anti-terrorisme d'abord parce qu'il ya
pas de baguette magique en matière
d'antiterrorisme mais c'est un outil qui
est quand même important pour avoir une
traçabilité sur des personnes suspectes
ça fait sept ans qu'on en débat quelles
sont les raisons pour lesquelles
maintenant on y va alors qu'on n'y allez
pas la pression avant qu une impression
politique la pression de l'émotion au
fond un peu quand c'est qu'on dirait
agir comme vient de le dire arnaud
danjean il y à la mise en scène de cette
histoire de pnr comme si au fond c'est
un peu le parlement européen l'europe
qui ne
donnait pas les moyens aux états de
lutter efficacement contre le terrorisme
qu'est ce qu'on a vu toutes ces
dernières années s'est toutes les
attaques terroristes tous les
terroristes était déjà fiché et
d'ailleurs dans votre sujet cazeneuve
parle du système d'information notre
outil par exemple les mouches qui avait
attaqué le musée juif de bruxelles ils
sont tous répertoriés là dedans
l'information avait été circulé mais mal
utilisé et au fond le risque c'est pas
que les écologistes sont contre le pnrc
qu'au fond on est en train plutôt que de
s'attaquer à l'est les insuffisances
criantes les défaillances criantes qui a
eu en matière de coopération en 2 comtal
de lutte contre le terrorisme
en matière de coopération policière en
matière de coopération des
renseignements en matière de coopération
de la justice plutôt que de dire au fond
après les attentats on a tellement à
faire mieux avec les outils existants la
plupart où tous les terroristes qui ont
agi était déjà répertoriée mais nous
n'avons pas mis en place ment pas
forcément mais nous n'avons pas mis en
place la coopération mais même s que
même ceux n'ayant à penne européen même
chose à paris l'avion nom maurice n'ont
pas pris l'avion 6 mai un peu à la
normale
même le mignan n'a plus cours
les enquêtes terroristes écoutez on
trouve encore aujourd'hui des suspects
sur des attentats terroristes qu'on lui
à paris au début des années 80 les
enquêtes terroristes aujourd'hui vous
pouvez pas dire de façon absolue et
péremptoire ça ne ça n'aurait servi à
rien vous ne pouvez pas le dire quand on
regarde les attentats de paris
précisément ceux du mois de janvier les
frères kwasi il ya des blancs dans la
bio des frères kwasi il ya des
déplacements à oman et au yémen il n'y
sont pas allés à la nage ici se voiler
un autobus ils ont pris l'avion sans
doute sous de fausses identités
sans doute avec des moyens en
tronçonnant leur voyage de façon à ce
qu'on puisse pas établir cette
traçabilité
donc je dis pas que ça aurait le disait
ce que disaient aussi le ministre
bulgare par exemple s'est dit moi si on
m'avait donné les informations
j'aurais pu contrôler à mai
après l'annonce plus pâle au moins
encore une fois si les états ne sont pas
trop souverain non mais la garde de la
formation constitue dit ce que c'est le
coordonnateur européen sur le terrorisme
c'est le cas il dit au fond les systèmes
de renseignement nationaux ont la
culture du secret et qui a un enjeu de
souveraineté nationale que les états
n'arrivent pas à dépasser pour faire une
meilleure coopération qu'on surveille et
qu'on collecte des informations sur tous
ceux qui sont suspects d'attentats
terroristes c'est une évidence absolue
mais attention parce qu'on est quand
même avec des moyens limités ce qu'on va
mettre sur le pnr y compris les
centaines de millions d'euros
on les mettra pas ailleurs or on sait or
on sait aujourd'hui que ce qui manque
terriblement dans l'international s'est
renforcé la coopération donc ce sont des
moyens humains et sociaux ne reviennent
pas d'accord de suivi des suspects
terroristes ou des terroristes qui sont
prêts à agir
je sais pas que suis pas d'accord l'un
n'est pas exclusive de l'autre bien sûr
qu'il faut plus de coordination une
meilleure coordination mais d'ailleurs
il faut arrêter de croire que les
services ne corps ne coordonne pas leurs
activités deuxièmement il faut plus de
conseillers a manqué entre la belgique
et la france le plus de coordination
mais ça n'exclut pas le fait de se doter
d'un pnr veut dire on est tous
conscients que le pnr encore une fois
n'est pas la baguette magique mais c'est
un outil qui serait un titre il doit
être un outil utile parmi d'autres il
faut des précautions dans son
utilisation mais encore une fois c'est
ce que je disais en introduction ne
croyait pas que l'ensemble des données
collectées par les compagnies aériennes
va être transférer massivement aux états
pour piocher dedans communes comme bon
leur semble il va falloir justifier ça
va faire comme les américains chacun
savoir sinon j'adore sera contrôle
judiciaire c'est un peu oui mais
attendez quand même y compris acheter
après les argentins initialisation n'est
pas forcément la solution
le tout judiciarisation n'est pas
forcément la solution en revanche le
fait qu'il n'y ait plus de contrôle
judiciaire sur des démarches et des
trucs de police sur le long terme pose
un problème de respect du droit et c'est
d'ailleurs en partie ce que dit ce qu'a
dit ce qu'a pu dire la cnil sur le parce
qu'il ya un pnr français il existe ce
pnr français jay hill
des échanges d'informations il ya même
depuis 2004 des échanges d'informations
sur les passagers entre les pays
européens
il ya eu il existe déjà des systèmes
d'information sur les valeurs et mais
même après les attentats de boston aux
états unis
ils ont y compris les républicains au
congrès ont revisité à la baisse les
pouvoirs de surveillance massive
le risque avec le fantasme si je peux
finir le plr n'est pas un instrument
mais bien sûr que mon tour mais déjà
chez les compagnies aériennes donc vous
ça ne vous choque pas que les compagnies
risque que des sociétés commerciales et
accès à toutes ces données mais que les
états ne l'est pas pour des raisons
sécuritaires télécom a ni sauf que les
compagnies aériennes doivent quasiment
les détruire après 24 heures
donc on a ici on est à 60 puisque la
mode c'est qu'on va pouvoir les retirer
pendant maintenant cinq ans dont oui
mais ça parce qu'on va changer le
système sont massés au bout de six mois
se sont massés sur d'ailleurs se sont
pas laissés seuls dans les ehpad et rial
et ce sont les compagnies aériennes qui
vont transférer un certain nombre
d'informations aux états selon qui
s'était aussi dans votre portable
selon certains profils la question c'est
aussi qu'est ce qu'un profil on est
toujours inquiet qu'effectivement sur la
base de vous manger casher ou vous
manger halal vous voyager seules
en passant par istanbul d'un seul coup
vous venez vous devenez potentiellement
un suspect si vous avez mis votre
garantie c'est ça qui ce qui menace si
vous avez mis votre frère en contact si
en cas de problème et benda secoue aussi
votre frère pétroliers le problème de
simple c'est à moi que moi je n'ai pas
de souci à ce qu'on surveille les
suspects bien sûr qu'il faut surveiller
les suspects mais comment ont programmé
un suisse mon problème larrouy mais le
mot en terminant sur le problème c'est
qu'à tous les annonces suspect non non
non le problème c'est qu'on a des
suspects en pagaille ils sont sur des
listes qui sont déjà faites et que c'est
suzon bay faune on a maintenant des
positions non mais c'est suspect qui
aujourd'hui opère tous les attaques en
europe depuis des années ils sont
répertoriés et qu'on n'a pas et qu'on a
pas les déplacer ils se déplacent en
voiture basse et ils se déplacent voirie
les places aussi en avion serait fausse
identité mais on a moyen moyen mais
passé lors des travaux aujourd'hui c'est
faux parce que quand les mouches quand
les mouches à un voyage et notamment à
berlin les autorités allemandes ont
transféré aux autorités françaises le
fait qu'un suspect
les en france après on a su qu'il était
revenue en voiture dans sa région de
tourcoing
juste avant qu'il fasse les infantes à
ce que je veux dire c'est que les sur la
liste des suspects est déjà large on n'a
pas les moyens de suivre ces suspects
aient cessées suspect qui créent des
attentats alors quand on est con
renforce avec d'autres informations
d'accord mais ne nous trompons pas de
priorité agissons et pas contre eux tout
le monde mais arrêtons de dire que le
pnr est un outil qui était adoptée sous
la contrainte de l'émotion vous l'avez
dit vous-même ça fait des années qu'il
est en discussion donc ça fait quand
même bien des années avant les attentats
spectaculaires qu'on a connus sur le sol
français et en europe de façon générale
ça fait bien longtemps que ce pnr de
discussion donc ça fait bien longtemps
que les polices et les services alerte
sur l'utilité de cet instrument
donc moi je récuse cour de justice
européenne consacrée c'est comme notre
conseil constitutionnel on peut pas agir
oui contre on considère être nos
libertés messieurs mental on a les
reconnaît qu'il ya une pression énorme
qui est de dire au fond c'est pas le
manque de coopération qui nous a plantés
sur les attaques
c'est d'un seul coup l'europe le pnr est
incertain on peut dire ça c'était un
terrain c'était faire ça on pu lire çà
n'est pas fair est encore une fois moi
je crois que les deux dimensions ne sont
pas exclusives l'une de l'autre
je pense qu'une meilleure coopération
n'exclut pas le fait que parallèlement
on adopte un pnr je crois même que ça va
bien dans le même sens
et pour ce qui est de la coordination
attention aussi je veux dire faire la
grèce ne va parler de ce système
d'information schengen qui serait pas
alimenter oui mais tu sais que j'ai mal
à l'immobilier d'abord c'est quoi ces
les services de renseignement qui chacun
pour soi en d'abord il faut bien faire
la différence entre des services de
renseignement et des services de police
le renseignement c'est quelque chose de
très particulier et un rasta raid-h pas
hein ça se partage mais ça se partage en
ayant conscience qu'il est obtenu par
des sources qui sont généralement des
sources clandestine des sources humaines
dont l'avis peut être en danger ou des
sources techniques qui sont là aussi
très pointu donc le partage des
renseignements il obéit à des règles
très strictes règles européennes vous
voulez pas absolument mêmes kerckhove
lui-même le coordinateur anti européen
européen anti terroriste dit très bien
que c'est irréaliste en l'état que les
choses et que ça n'apporterait pas
forcément une plus value jeudi toujours
le renseignement le renseignement pas
l'information judiciaire ou policière le
renseignement sert très en amont le
renseignement avant de le partager il
faut le collecter et pour le collecter
il faut des moyens
opérationnels qui sont généralement au
plus près du terrain donc géré par les
états après d'enlever leurs tâches plus
dans les plateformes de partage et la
coopération plateforme de partage on
peut renforcer un certain nombre de il
ya certains noms de tuyauterie si vous
voulez qu'ils sont pas assez connectés
ça c'est une réalité et c'est ce qu'il
faut essayer de faire au niveau européen
avec un brillant nava avec un autre
outil par exemple qui serait un
procureur européen là-dessus au niveau
national on est d'accord parce qu'on a
vu par exemple que sur les les enquêtes
au niveau des attentats à paris le 13
novembre dernier entre le parquet belge
et le parquet français y avait des
incohérences extraordinaire dans les
capacités dans la stratégie d' enquête
et c'est totalement absurde parce que au
fond je sais pas quel peut être l'impact
de ce manque de cohérence entre deux
parcs et de pays voisins
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ça aide
pas à l'efficacité de l'anc est donc un
parquet européen avec des enquêteurs et
des moyens européens d'investir était
beaucoup de choses qu'on peut harmoniser
en aval si vous voulez des actions sur
des échanges de la volonté de la
commission de créer un corps de gardes
frontières pour sécuriser schengen
céline ans si on à la libre circulation
à l'intérieur de l'espace schengen il
faut évidemment des moyens de contrôles
aux frontières
moi je suis absolument d'accord avec le
principe le diable est toujours dans les
détails surtout au niveau de l'europe si
oui il faut faire attention à ce qu'on
ne crée pas des bureaucraties
supplémentaires qui font que
opérationnellement ça ne marche pas donc
l'idée est bonne le principe est bon la
mise en oeuvre dans ce qu'on nous en
explique aujourd'hui me paraît aller
dans le bon sens en articulant bien ce
qui est fait au niveau européen
mutualiser et au niveau des ressources
que les états devront mettre à
disposition avec une confusion très
forte à éviter c'est qu'on mélange la
question des migrations et la question
de la lutte contre le terrorisme et dans
le débat aujourd'hui on est loin d'
éviter cette confusion et ça c'est très
dangereux
merci yannick jadot d'avoir accepté
notre invitation merci arnaud danjean
d'avoir accepté notre invitation tout de
suite direction madrid en espagne les
élections législatives là bas c'est en
quelques jours le 20 décembre et l'issue
du scrutin reste un mystère il ya les
partis traditionnels en perte de vitesse
et à ceux plus jeunes qui montent
podemos le parti de la gauche radicale
et il ya aussi l'étoile montante le
parti soudas danos le parti des citoyens
qui se positionne au centre droit le
tout dans un pays qui situe
l'avant-dernière place des états membres
de la zone euro avec plus de 20% de la
population qui est aujourd'hui sans
emploi leur portage à madrid de rym ben
ameur
ils ont moins de 40 ans le style est
décontractée voici les deux nouveaux
visages de la politique espagnole à
gauche pablo iglesias leader de podemos
le parti d'extrême gauche qui montrent à
chaque élection depuis un an et demi à
droite albert rivera le candidat
centriste de ciudadanos qui fait une
percée fracassante dans la sphère
politique
des centaines de militants survoltés et
des médias espagnols venus très nombreux
un accueil de star pour albert rivera le
leader de ciudadanos il est désormais
créditée de près de 20% des intentions
de vote un parti qui a beaucoup recruté
parmi les chefs d'entreprise et les
travailleurs en bref un parti pas comme
les autres pour la première fois en
espagne un parti issu de la société
civile va concurrencer les deux vieux
partis pour ouvrir une nouvelle étape
politique
nous sommes sur le point de réaliser
quelque chose d'historique un parti né
il ya dix ans à barcelone et qui s'est
étendue dans toute l'espagne peut gagner
des élections face au parti socialiste
et au parti populaire
enfin enfin kova est l'une des nouvelles
militantes de ce parti cette ancienne
étudiante en sciences politiques à
participer au grand mouvement de
contestation du 15 mai 2011 le mouvement
des indignés
depuis deux mois elle a choisi de se
tourner vers ciudadanos le parti du
changement selon elle dans toute
l'histoire de notre démocratie ça a été
un duel classique parti socialiste parti
populaire parti socialiste parti
populaire droite gauche droite gauche
il était temps qu'un autre parti arrive
enfin et il ya toutes ces affaires de
corruption
ce parti n'a jamais gouverné s'adonne
donc de l'air frais aux institutions à
l'administration et à la manière de
faire de la politique
ce jour là l'institut de sondage
metroscopia réalise une enquête sur la
perception des quatre grands candidats à
l'élection aucun doute le paysage
politique a changé
zidane hausse est presque à égalité avec
les deux grands partis le parti
populaire et le parti socialiste alors
que podemos par rapport à leurs débuts
où il était presque leader dans les
sondages ont baissé mais ils ont
toujours des appuis politiques forts qui
ne faiblirons pas les élections podemos
est l'autre acteur majeur de cette
élection
ce parti s'organise en cercles de
discussion par cartier dans le cercle de
lava pièces l'une des antennes
historique de madrid
les militants lancent la campagne en
petit comité
je remercie tous ceux qui sont là vous
allez participer à cette campagne
allez dans les rues les marchés là où
les gens vivent pour leur faire partager
notre message que le changement est
proche
javier milita podemos depuis un an les
sondages qui donnent son parti en baisse
à environ 18% d'intentions de vote il
n'y croit pas vraiment avec podemos les
sondages n'ont jamais eu raison il n'y
avait pas de bon pronostic
comme nous sommes présentés aux
élections locales de mai aucun sondage
n'a prévu cada colao gagnerait à
barcelone où que manuela carmena
deviendra maire de madrid
la sélection européenne et nous donnait
deux députés on en a eu cinq dès le
lendemain matin les militants du cercle
lava thiès sont dans l'arbre pour
convaincre les nouveaux électeurs
voilà notre programme électoral ce sont
les mesures concrètes veut appliquer si
on gouverne
moi je suis presque convaincu
je voulais juste quelques consignes
encore quelques jours pour gagner des
voix et rivaliser avec les scores de
ciudadanos francesco magnéto suit le
parti podemos pour le journal el país il
constate une érosion de l'intérêt
médiatique depuis la naissance du parti
c'était du jamais vu dans le paysage
politique
on voulait comprendre ce parti il avait
des nouveaux codes et ont changé la
manière de faire de la politique mais il
y a eu un gâchis médiatique du parti et
surtout de ses leaders
on les a vus partout dans les médias et
ça leur a coûté cher avec quatre parties
au coude à coude
cette élection du 20 décembre est la
plus disputés de l'histoire politique
espagnole quel que soit le résultat
elle pourrait signer la fin du
bipartisme en espagne
voilà un reportage à madrid de rim
benameur alors nous a rejoints sur ce
plateau et d'heures guardian à bâle
rubiales bonjour vous êtes député du
groupe de l'alliance progressiste des
socialistes et démocrates au parlement
européen membre du parti socialiste
ouvrier espagnol l'un des principaux
partis avec le parti populaire qui
dirige l'espagne depuis 40 ans 1 depuis
la transition démocratique après la
dictature de franco
on a vu le reportage j'ai envie de vous
demander aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on
n'assiste pas à la fin du bipartisme
votre parti le parti socialiste le parti
populaire jeté aux oubliettes et
l'émergence d'une nouvelle scène
politique plus jeune je ne crois pas
vraiment en fait
on parle beaucoup du bipartisme et en
espagne si on regarde aujourd'hui le
congrès des députés il est accrue huit
groupes politiques donc y en a pas un
vrai bipartisme mais c'est vrai que dans
l'exercice du pouvoir dans l'exercice du
pouvoir l'alternance de groupes
politiques qui ont étaient
majoritairement appuyé par les par les
citoyens espagnols et ça a était le
parti populaire et le parti socialiste
je pense que ça va pas changer il ya le
parti succède à l'os dont une à vis
d'elle d'albert y verra qui est qui
serait placé selon ce sondage
en deuxième position devant votre parti
le parti socialiste il ya eu beaucoup de
sondages et c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident de voir avec de nouveaux partis
qui sont sur scène politique c'est pas
très facile à voir ce qui peut arriver
la fin décembre mais de toute façon je
pense que il ya où le parti populaire le
parti socialiste qui pourront gagner
cette élection
on a l'impression que podemos acquis
issus du mouvement des indignés veut
remplacer à gauche
votre parti le parti socialiste et
ciudadano ce qui est un peu centre doit
veut remplacer le parti populaire oui je
pense que ces intérêts de ces nouveaux
partis mais il ya deux choses qui sont
assez contradictoires
u ne sait que en fait ce qu'ils ont fait
pour l'instant c'est pour démence il a
remplacé un peu le parti communiste le
parti plus à gauche du parti socialiste
et tout va à nancy l'a remplacé à notre
parti qui est ressorti à 10 ans à peu
près qui s'appelle loupé des donc ils
n'ont pas vraiment attaqué le parti
populaire le parti socialiste mais en
fait ils veulent remplacer le parti
populaire le parti socialiste dont il
veut pas le faire selon vous
non je ne crois pas mais même moi ce qui
me paraît un peu choquant c'est que ils
veulent finir avec le bipartisme
mais en fait ce qu'ils veulent c'est
remplacer louis partie des mannequins il
triche un peu avec le message c'est
justement les partis traditionnels ils
continuent à s'affronter un de façon
parfois tendues regarder cet échange
lors d'un débat entre le chef du
gouvernement conservateur espagnol
mariano rajoy son challenger socialiste
pedro sanchez
le 20 décembre les espagnols vont devoir
choisir librement par leur vote la
personne qui sera le prochain chef du
gouvernement
maintenant oui je vous préviens si vous
restez à la tête du gouvernement
le coût pour notre démocratie et pour
l'institution que vous voulez
représenter sera énorme parce que le
chef du gouvernement monsieur lacroix
doit être une personne descente et vous
ne l'êtes pas ce dont on ne se remet pas
c'est une affirmation ville misérable
mesquine comme celles que vous avez fait
ici ça vous ne vous en remettrez jamais
si vous avez quelque chose contre moi
attaquer mois en justice mais je ne suis
pas disposé à vous laisser m'attaquer
sur des questions d'honneur
c'est assez tendue pedro sanchez qui
attaque le premier ministre sur son
bilan surtout en matière de corruption
et la corruption de la classe politique
traditionnelle est ce que c'est pas ça
qui a fait fuir les électeurs
je pense que les électeurs et il on est
un peu un peu peur de tout ce qui s'est
passé en espagne depuis la crise
économique qui n'a pas de cause unique
au strict plan d'austérité c'est ça
c'est pas seulement l'espagne
malheureusement c'est dans toute
l'europe est presque dans la plupart du
monde mais c'est vrai que dans ce débat
politique au ps de chance et il a
vraiment attaqué le premier ministre
dans la corruption parce que nous avons
un mini un premier ministre qui a envoyé
un sms au trésorier du parti populaire
qui était en prison il a dit il faut que
tu te maintiennent il faut que tu te
dire locaux c'est incroyable comment on
peut pas attaquer un premier ministre
quand il a fait ça l'interruption de
leur parti populaire c'est incroyable
c'est vraiment dans le centre du parti
et il faut qu'il rentre à la maison il
faut qu'il fasse un vrai travail de
changer le parti politique et ses salles
ce que vraiment les citoyens elle
demande et citoyens lui demandant la
classe politique qu'on soit honnête et
c'est normal vous êtes membre du parti
socialiste français est jeune mais les
jeunes on les voit plus touchées aux
démos sont 37 ans à son son leader
leader de 2
soudano 35 ans je pense oui la laideur
et là quarante trois ans c'est quand
même assez jeunes pour la politique
d'accord l'espagne elle a adhéré à
l'union européenne en 1986 est ce
qu'aujourd'hui après tout ce qui s'est
passé
les espagnols ont encore soif d'europe
oui il a encore soif d'europe où est-ce
qu'on se referme
non non les espagnols ils ont encore
soif d'europe nous avons un grand soir
de val d'europe
mais c'est vrai que nous n'aimons pas
l'europe que nous avons vécu pendant les
dernières dix années surtout après la
crise économique c'est quoi cette europe
là ça a été une robe de l'austérité une
europe de l'imposition une europe de la
troïka et les espagnols ils ont eu un
passé je pense que les européens en
général ils n'aiment pas ça nous avons
été très très européen pour nous
regarder vers l'europe et faire partir
de l'europe c'était la liberté c'était
la croissance économique
et c'était l'égalité des citoyens et
c'est le koala vous en nous avons vu que
vous jouerez menti non nous a pas menti
et d'ailleurs depuis le 86 jusqu'à
l'année 2005 2006 2007
c'est l'europe marché assez bien
évidemment il ya toujours eu des
problèmes et il faut toujours continuer
à créer ce projet europe qui n'est
jamais fini mais c'est vrai que nous ne
pouvons pas centrer la politique
européenne était dans la sortie de crise
oui la bulle immobilière oui oui c'est
ça mais il faut que nous changions
l'europe et c'est pour ça que ici au
parlement européen où nous plaidons pour
ne pas parler que de l'austérité est
surtout de l'égalité des citoyens
en tout cas merci madame d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et merci à vous nous
avoir suivis c'est la fin de repas bio
on se retrouve l'année prochaine au
parlement européen d'ici là passez de
bonnes fêtes et rester avec nous sur les
chaînes parlementaires bail